The chronological end of the Old Testament
Hebrew Bible takes place in the sixth
century BCE that is in
the five hundreds BCE.
I say the chronological end of the text
is that because that's actually not the
latest that our literature comes from a,
it's just, that's the end of the story.
What happens basically is that, uh,
the Jews are taken out of Judea,
they're taken into captivity,
or at least the upperclass is in Babylon,
and then they wait 70 years.
And in that brought,
they're allowed to come back into Judea
to rebuild the temple and the walls of
Jerusalem. And it's the rebuilding
of the material, the tear,
the temple and the walls of Jerusalem
that are narrated in the books,
Ezra and Nehemiah.
But then that's kind of where
the story of the Jews are.
The Israelites ends, uh, at the
end of the sixth century BCE.
That's not actually the latest document
because as we'll talk about a little bit
later today, the book of Daniel,
which claims of course to be,
to be written in Babylon,
Babylonian captivity, but also, uh,
by a guy named Daniel who
lived in the sixth century.
It's actually not written then.
It's written around the year one 64 BCE.
So that's the latest document that we
have that's in the Hebrew Bible or the Old
Testament. So there's a difference in
the actual timing of the documents. Uh,
and the chronological end of the story,
I'll remind you of what we talked about
last time with Alexander the Great,
just very briefly, Alexander the great,
remember wanting to set up a oneworld,
a unify, a universal empire. He,
he taught us sort of syncretism
of religion. He taught a
common language, Greek,
he set up these Greek cities all around
these things will all be very important
for us. Uh, in that process that we
call is what we call Hellenization.
So the Hellenization of the world in
that time means that we even call that
period Hellenistic Greek,
the Hellenistic period,
to differentiate it from
classical Greek period,
say classical Athens in the fifth
and sixth and fifth century,
and then the Greco Roman period,
which will come later the period of Rome.
The reason Hellenism is so important for
us is because Alexander what happened
to us in power after he died,
after much confusion and fighting among
his major generals, uh, after his death,
Alexander's kingdom ended up being
divided up into four major empires.
For our purposes,
only three of those really matter.
And on your handout you'll see the name
Salukis and Antiochus and the solutions.
Salukis was one of the
generals of Alexander and he
ended up getting the part of
his empire that had been Babylonia.
That is modern day Iraq and Syria.
And what happens is you'll find over and
over again, that's an a man named Lucas.
We'll have a kid named maybe Antiochus
who I'll have a kid named Lucas who,
Alvin cadamen ticas. The solutions
was what we call their dynasty,
their family name.
They tended to use those two names.
Salukis Lucas and entire cuss a lot. So
you'll see just Salukis the first, second,
third, and Ticus the first,
second, third and forth.
Those two names were used quite in
their family over and over again.
So it gets very confusing and historical
literature when it's hard to keep them
straight. But that's the reason his
general Ptolemy, the second, uh,
got the kingdom of Egypt,
which was very,
very important because Egypt was one
of the wealthiest parts of the ancient
world.
So Ptolemy,
the second t took Egypt and set up his
own sort of Greco Egyptian kingdom there.
So when we talk about these things,
sometimes you'll,
you'll hear us talk about
the Syrian empire or the
Greco steer empower or simply
the Greek empire.
That's because there was a Greek sort
of the near over what would have been
local differences. So you'd have Egyptian
speaking ancient Egyptian languages,
but the elites in the cities would
be speaking Greek. So the culture,
the elite culture was to be Greek.
And the same way in Syria,
Tommy's are easier to keep
straight because they tended
to all be named Ptolemy.
And so they might have
a nickname like Ptolemy.
Philadelphia is a very famous one, but
then they get, we give them numbers.
So Ptolemy, the second was the first
general who ruled Egypt and then his, uh,
assets is DC. Um, descendants would
be named second, third, fourth,
and that sort of that so forth.
The other empire that was important but
will not talk about it too much today is
what was Macedonia and Greece itself.
And the general antagonists Gennady us
was the one who took that and that would
be its own sort of area until the Romans,
uh,
defeated the different Greek rulers
there and took over Macedonia and Greece.
What's important for us though,
it was really the solutions and the
Ptolemies because if you draw a line
separating Syria from Egypt,
the line goes right through Palestine.
The Jews were kind of caught
therefore on the border. So Judea,
uh, at this time was on the border
between these two empires and they were
constantly fighting,
trying to aggrandize their own kingdoms.
The Jews were often therefore caught
right in the middle and tie cost.
The fourth epiphany's rain
from one 75 to one 64 BCE,
he's called the fourth obviously
cause he's in the fourth of Antiochus.
Epiphanes though is a sort of
nickname and it means manifest.
It's just a Greek word for manifest.
But what Antiochus was doing with this
name is saying he was claiming divine
honors for himself because what
he's saying is, I'm in Tacos.
God made manifest among you.
This was not that unusual.
Uh, as I said last time, Alexander had
sort of claimed divine honors from self.
He was following the lead of a lot of
eastern monarchs and rulers who would
claim to be the descendants of a god
and claim to be a god themselves would
receive cult and worship. And Taika is
the fourth though was ruling at this time.
And he had control. He
gained control of Judea. He,
at one point, he almost conquered
Egypt. As a matter of fact, he, again,
there were always these battles,
but then Rome intervene.
Rome was not in control of the
eastern Mediterranean at this time,
but they started getting
more and more powerful.
So Rome came to Egypt and a
Roman general basically said,
you've got to withdraw and forced and
Tacos to forth to pull out of Egypt.
Why did Rome do that?
While Rome wanted Rome didn't want any
other empire in the Mediterranean to get
too powerful.
So they wanted small,
they didn't want to really control all
the eastern part of that train at this
time.
They would have been stretched too thin,
but they wanted these two kingdoms to
balance each other out. So they didn't,
they weren't particularly for,
and Tacos the fourth,
they just didn't want him to destroy the
Egyptian Ptolemies and him to take over,
eat it because it would make
him too powerful. So Ron,
those shows that they have enough power
that they can kind of, uh, play, uh,
the referee, uh, between different
kingdoms, even in the east of this time.
What, while Judea though
was under Antiochus control,
a lot of Jews tried to figure out how
do you deal with this whole process of
Hellenization.
In other words,
if you want your own kids to get ahead
in the world in this time and you're
going to have an elite family
yourself and a town and a city,
it makes sense for your kids to get a
Greek education. You want your sons,
for example, to be able to speak
and read and write Greek. Why?
Because that's the Lingua
Franca of the elite,
of the business and of government and
all that sort of thing is precisely the
way it is now with English
around the world. Uh,
elite families want their kids
to have English education.
They want them to be familiar with
American culture. And if possible,
they'll even send them to a
university in the states, uh,
are to graduate school in the states.
And this is part partly because there
are a good universities in the states,
but it's also partly because
they know that, but to get ahead,
there are kids need to use English.
They need to be become in some sense,
to some extent, Americanized.
This is what's going on.
Even in places like Jerusalem. At this
time, Jerusalem wasn't a huge city,
but it was important enough that
there were elites. They're themselves.
And so when they responded to this urge
of hellenized culture to have their kids
educated in the goon
nauseum, remember, uh,
that so they would themselves get this
sort of Greek rhetorical education.
In fact,
what we'll call for the purposes
liberals and conservatives and Jerusalem,
because there was conflict in Jerusalem
at this time over how much Hellenization
you should go along with apparently a
majority of the priests and the lay no
milk nobility supported the
hellenized group. That is the,
the one that the Jewish leaders who
wanted to bring more Hellenization into
Jerusalem itself. The high priests
at this time was named Jason.
His name was on here
and in one 75,
he built a gymnasium in Jerusalem.
Why did he build a gymnasium in Jerusalem?
Well,
if you're going to have Greek education,
you have to have a good ad nauseum. This.
He also founded a Greek Polis
that is a Greek city structure.
And Jason apparently paid Antiochus
for the privilege of having Jerusalem
recognized as a Greek city.
This would have consolidated the power
of those Jewish leaders who wanted to
press Greek culture more rather than
those Jewish leaders who want it to hold
back on Greek culture.
The cause,
if you control the gymnasium and
you control the means of education,
you actually control the citizenry because
you can't become a citizen of a Greek
Polis, a Greek city, unless you yourself
have Greek education. So sons would,
uh, sons of people would go
to dig of nauseum and notice
what this would do. Also,
it would disenfranchise those leading
families who didn't want to have their
sons hellenized. So by holding
the control of the education,
you disenfranchise conservative Jews
who are resisting this Greek influence
about this time, apparently Antiochus
offered citizenship status to the Jews.
But, and like I said, admission to the
gum nauseum and the EFA debate member,
the EFA Bait,
we talked about how the boys around the
year [inaudible] 18 to 22 or so around
the age that you guys are,
you have to be enrolled in this
sort of quasi education quality,
quasi military training,
uh,
club sort of thing of the
town that was the Efa Bait.
And you had to go through
that to be a citizen.
Jason and his party controlled this
and in fact they renamed Drew's, uh,
Jerusalem,
Antioch of Jerusalem.
There are lots of different
cities named Antioch, uh,
in the ancient world and we're all
done in honor of and some Antiochus.
So Jerusalem is renamed
Antioch of Jerusalem.
Yeah.
The high priesthood was the main
ruler of the Jews at this time.
They didn't have a king and
didn't have a direct governor.
So where whoever controlled
the high priesthood with
sort of the political ruler
also at this time,
but Antiochus was the one who had the
privilege of appointing the high priest.
Min allows another leading
Jew. It's names on your, uh,
handout seems to have offered and tie
because more money for the priesthood
trying to get it away from
Jason and he couldn't afford it.
So in order to pay for his own priesthood,
he took gold vessels and instruments
out of the temple treasury.
And this seems to have caused a riot.
Now notice
Jason,
is that a good Jewish name?
No,
that's not a good Jewish name.
Men allows,
is that a Jewish name?
No.
Jason and mental health are
both famous Greek names.
You have two guys fighting for
the high priesthood in Jerusalem,
both with Greek names,
not traditional Hebrew names.
And both of them apparently trying to
get in with his hellenized process.
They get into a big fight to
settle things down in Jerusalem.
Antiochus takes control of Jerusalem
and he stationed Syrian troops that he's
the Greco Syrian troops
in Jerusalem and one 67.
Now things are heating
up around this time.
Changes were made to
the temple in Jerusalem.
It may have been basically
to accommodate the soldiers.
They may have had to house, uh, soldiers
from the Greco, Syria and empire.
And they may have used the Temple
Mount apparently to house some of them.
This caused changes to
the temple at this time.
Men allows is in charge
and his Helen Ising party,
which we could call the radical reformers,
they saw this lady's the beginning of
the Anti Judaism laws about this time.
Uh, several laws were passed
that for bad circumcision,
you can't circumcise your boys anymore.
You're forbidden from observing the Torah,
the Jewish law.
It may have been that even a pig was
sacrificed on the altar in Jerusalem,
in the holy of holies.
And the temple was turned into a
syncretistic Jewish Pagan Grove.
You know, in Greek, traditional
Greek religion and other religions.
Having a grove of trees is sort
of considered the sacred area.
It's like when you walk through a forest
now and you come upon a nice open kind
of grove of trees and all of a sudden
you just kind of feel like, you know,
some men for something is going to jump
out at you and you know, God is there.
So the Greeks liked these sorts
of groves of trees. So they,
this is often what they
would use as a sacred area,
that they did this to the temple and it
was renamed as a shrine to Zeus, Olympus.
Now notice what's happened.
I talked about syncretism last time.
If you're one of these liberal Jews,
you may not really believe
you're doing anything bad.
You're not forsaking Judaism,
you're just updating it.
You're just bringing it up in the
modern era and you had to say, well,
what's wrong with calling it Zeus?
Olympus?
We all know these are just different
names given to the same God. Anyway,
there's this one,
supreme god,
so they may well have identified the
Jewish God ya'll way with this god Zeus
Olympus and said,
it's just two different names.
One Greek name and one Jewish
name for the same Jewish God.
That may have been what
they were thinking about.
That could also have been thinking
about this Syrian God by all that,
by all mom was a Syrian God,
so they just saying, well,
we'll have an altar here and Ticus will
be happy because we're worshiping this
Syrian God here. The Greeks are
happy with were springs Zeus,
Olympus and the Jews will be happy
because it's identified as Yahweh.
This whole process of Hellenization,
therefore I'm interpreting this and a
lot of history books times you'll get the
idea that the Jews were all good, loyal
Jews. Just trying to keep the law,
trying to keep Torah
and that the antichrist,
the for the epiphany's is putting all
this on them and forcing Greek religion in
Greek culture on them.
That's not really the way it happened.
I've told the story the way I perceive
if you read between the lines of some of
these ancient Jewish texts,
it's more like it's a,
it's a debate that's going
on within Judaism itself.
How Greek should we be?
How much do you accommodate
the dominant culture?
Precisely the way you get a lot of this
kind of debate in the modern world.
Our time of how much
do you want your kids,
your Jewish boys and girls to assimilate
to be just as American as everybody
else? How much intermarriage do
you want to have or do you allow?
If you're a Muslim and immigrant to the,
to this country, the first generation,
do you let them listen to hip hop? Do you
let the women stop covering their hair?
Where,
where do you draw the line?
What I'm arguing is that this was what
was going on and it was an internal
Jewish conflict that was going on.
There were several responses to the
Hellenization. Therefore among Jews,
it wasn't just that the Helen I that
Greeks are here putting this onto Jews.
There were just responses within Judaism
itself, as I've already said, Mina, Laos,
and the liberals except it and promote it.
Another priest that had been dislocated
from the high priesthood earlier,
who his family had originally been the
high priesthood family, Oneidas, I think.
Oh Nice. The fourth is on
your hand up there. Oh, nice.
The fourth actually withdrew
from Jerusalem and went
off and built a new temple.
So he says, well, if you're gonna
destroy the existing Jewish temple,
we're going to have an
alternative temple elsewhere.
You also have these people that come
to be called the Hasa deem it's on your
handout.
That's from a Hebrew word,
meaning the holy ones are pious
ones or something like that.
And they're not to be confused with the
modern Hasa deem who live in Brooklyn
under and who come from eastern Europe.
That's a modern movement that came about
in the medieval period and has come
through. But this the same
word used for these people.
These were Jews who decided to be very
strict and they seem to reject a lot of
Greek culture. They certainly rejected
Greek religion and Greek sacrifice.
They seem to promoted
the speaking of Hebrew,
the use of Hebrew texts
and particularly pious, uh,
observations of Jewish law.
You even have a group of high priest,
a former high priests who had been
dislocated and other priestly families
withdrawing from Jerusalem and apparently
going out in the desert and maybe
building a community out there.
And we find out about them.
And the 20th century when the Dead Sea
scrolls were discovered in the late 1940s.
And so there are a lot of the theories
are these dead sea scrolls were the
writings of a sect of Jews led bri
people who had been priestly families who
moved out into the desert,
set up camp on the shores of the
Dead Sea and had their own little.
So maybe cause I'm monastic community,
they're very strict in their
observation of the law.
They keep their documents, they have
some documents in Greek, some in Hebrews.
I'm an Aramaic.
So that may have been another way to
respond to this increasing halalization is
just to pull away and form
a different community.
And then you have the
reaction of [inaudible] bias.
Matt [inaudible] was a
priest from Jerusalem who
had settled in a village in a
called Modine and the
hill country of Judea.
And apparently according to the
texts that come down to us, uh,
some of which have to be sort of legends
and that sort of thing, hero worship.
But the story goes that mattifies was in
his village and a priest and a soldier
come from Jerusalem to the village and
they're trying to force the Jews to
sacrifice on an altar. Now what an
alter is most of the time is the,
y'all see this little, uh, base over there
in the corner. There's just a little,
a pillar that might be this high and to
offer something you don't actually have
to sacrifice a chicken
or anything like that.
You can have obviously sacrificed animals,
but you can just pour out some wine or
you can of course some grain or something
like that on the altar and burned it up.
And that will suffice as an offering
to a god without killing an animal.
Something like this may have
been going on. Mac, Matthias,
it is said took the sword away from the
soldier and killed this priest and the
soldier for encouraging Jews in his
village to sacrifice to the gods.
This was course was against the law.
So Matthias runs off to the hills,
taking his family with him,
his sons,
he had several sons and
this is the beginning of the
war that comes to be called
the Maccabean revolt.
It's called Maccabean because
after Matt [inaudible] has died,
shortly thereafter, he was the leader
of the revolt and beginning his son,
Judas becomes the head general
of the, of the bunch. Uh,
and Judas early on named earned the
nickname maccabaeus and we're not really
sure what the nickname means,
where it comes from.
It could be something like the hammer.
So you know,
he could be due to the
hammer. Uh, but it may have,
it may have been an attribute from him
being a very good general and winning a
lot of battles.
But against all odds,
this rag tag bunch of basically guerrilla
fighters up against a far superior
army of the, of Antiochus, the
fourth epiphany's, they beat them.
They retook Jerusalem.
They didn't actually beat them in Syria.
They just beat them
several battles and Judah.
And Judas was able to recapture
Jerusalem and the temple.
And in the year one 64,
they cleanse the temple
of the Prophet nation,
the pollution of having maybe pigs
and things like that sacrificed being
polluted as a Greek temple.
And so one 64 is the beginning of the,
the celebration of the Jewish holiday,
Hanukkah. Oh, Hanukkah song. Now,
no, we don't seem to Hanukah song.
So one 64 and the cleansing of the temple
is what Jews celebrate with Hanukkah.
Judas Maccabeus reigned as not
an official king at that point,
but he reigned over Judea of this time
and there was still battles that rage
between him and his family and his
army and talk is the fourth epiphany's.
And then other descendants after he died,
his brother,
one of his brothers became the leader and
then another brother became the leader.
Gradually, uh, these different, uh, uh,
people of this family came to set up
their own dynasty of rulers themselves.
Their family name was not Maccabeus,
that was just a nickname.
The family name was [inaudible]. And so
we call this the has money and dynasty.
That's the descendants of Mathias.
Some of them actually
were then proclaimed king.
There were recognized as with the
title king by the later rulers of the
neighboring areas like the,
the Syria, Greco Syrian empire.
So that has many in die
dynasty was empower from the
year one 65 to the year 60
BCE.
Now
that's the way one people responded to
this as they revolted against the rulers.
But another way p some Jews
responded was by bleeding.
That military volt wasn't the way to go,
that God would somehow
intervene miraculously,
that God was sent an angel or some
kind of heavenly figured down to Earth,
and an army of heavenly figures would
defeat Antiochus and usher in the New
Kingdom of Israel.
And that's where you get the story
of that from the book of Daniel.
So I asked you to read Daniel, uh, at
least the last part of Daniel for today.
If you've got your bibles,
take it out and turn with me
first to Daniel chapter nine.
I'm Chapter Eight,
verse 20.
Now the book of Daniel is in two halves.
The first half of it tells about the
adventures of this young man Daniels,
who's very,
very wise and very smart and very loyal,
and who refuses to
worship the Persian God.
And of course this is,
these are more Allity stories written
for Jews who were living under Greek
domination, encouraging them
not to a worship Greek gods,
but it's cast in the,
in the distant past.
Then the second half of Daniel is a
whole series of visions and prophecies.
And Daniel says, I was in a dream. I
was in the vision on the, on the day,
and I saw this and this angel told
me to this and this person did this.
And so it's a narration of
the history of humankind.
That's part of which has already
happened by Daniel time enter.
But most of which has to happen
in the future for Daniel.
And some of this stuff actually does
happen. So for example, uh, end,
he tells about different beasts. There's
the ram that does this. There's the,
BCIT does this,
but [inaudible] you know that these beasts
represent different kingdoms because
in chapter eight, verse 20, he says,
as for the ram that you saw in
your vision with the two horns,
these are the kings of media and Persia,
okay?
There was the kingdom of the meat and
the kingdom with the Persians who came
together under Cyrus.
The male goat is the king of Greece,
and the Great Horn between
its eyes is the first king.
So that would be Philip
Alexander's father.
As for the horn that was broken in place
of which four others arose for kingdom
shall arise from his nation
but not with his power.
So this is Alexander his,
he's broken and his kingdom is divided
into four empires like I told you about
earlier.
But none of those four empires enjoys
the same power that Alexander the great
enjoyed with his.
So now notice how you're already given
clue right here in Daniel that these
different images,
these different beasts are to refer to
kingdoms that are going to come in the
future. From Daniel's perspective, we
know actually that they already did.
Then what happens in Daniel
is in each different chapter,
the last part of Daniel in a sense,
tells the story over again.
He has another vision,
and instead of reading it chronologically
as if chapter nine told about one
century, then chapter 10 or chapter 11
in the next century, the next century,
you actually have to
read them like cycles.
Because what Daniel's doing is he's
giving you a prophecy of what's going to
happen politically related to the,
to Judea,
but he's given to you in several different
visions that all tell the same story
just in different kinds of symbols.
So turn over now to chapter 11.
Uh,
here again,
it's sort of like the
fourth chapter 11 verse two.
The four shall be far
richer than all of them.
When he has become strong to his riches,
he shall stir up all against
the Kingdom of Greece.
So this is actually talking about the
Persian ruler who will attack Greece.
Then a warrior king shall arise
who sharrow with great dominion.
That's Alexander,
while still rising in power,
Alexander member was still young and
increasing his power when he died.
His kingdom shall be broken and
divided to the four winds of heaven,
but not to his posterity. Alexander
had a child, but the child dies.
Alexander's Kingdom did not go
to any of his own offspring.
It went to these other four generals.
Then notice in verse five,
then the King of the south shall
grow strong. And the next verse,
the daughter of the king of the South
shall come to the king of the north to
ratify the agreement. Okay.
What's the king of the south?
Who's the king of the south?
Ptolemy? Some Ptolemy.
One of the Ptolemies. So whenever
you see king of the south in Daniel,
it's always referring to the top
Ptolemaic dynasty, one of the Ptolemies,
who's the king of the
North Salukis or Antiochus.
So whenever you see the king of the north,
it refers to one of the solutions.
So over and over again in Daniel,
you're going to get the king of the north,
the king of this out the king of the
north. And notice how it says, um,
the daughter of the king of the South
shall come to the king of the north to
ratify the agreement.
And if you look down,
if you have a study Bible and
you look at your footnotes,
it'll actually give you the names of
these different people that historians can
identify. So it's like, oh,
this may be because we know that she
was a daughter and Antiochus or Salukis,
she was married to one of these
Ptolemies if you follow in your,
your study about it and it has to be a
good critical study Bible. I mean, if you,
uh, you know, by real
scholars, if you use, you know,
these bibles that take all
this as prophecy that relates
to the Soviet Union or
to Russia, you know, they might
tell you things like, well,
the king of the north here refers to,
um, you know, the head of the, uh,
pullet borough or something like this.
And, and, uh, so if it's, if it's a,
a Bible by some by contemporary
church that takes all,
this is referring to our time at the time,
immediately the future,
which of course a lot of Christians do,
then their footnotes might be different.
But the footnotes in any good study Bible,
we'll place these people to the history
of what's going on in Judea as this time.
Now go over
to chapter 11 verse 29
Cause I'm not gonna lead you through all
this stuff that happens in chapter 11
because if you read it and you read it
with the footnotes is basically telling
you a history of the battles and
alliances between the solutions and the
Ptolemies and where Judea was caught
in the middle at different times at the
time appointed, he shall return and
come into the south. This is um,
one of the, this is Antiochus
not intact is fourth be doing,
but this time it should not be
as before four ships of ca team
shall come against him and he shall lose
heart and withdraw. Who are the QA team?
Romans.
Exactly.
The Qa team is a term that's
used in Hebrew in a lot of
different ancient Jewish
texts and sometimes it seems
to refer to the Greeks.
And here it's clearly refers to the
Romans because the Romans come and they
forced the king of the North back. Notice
what it says, forces sent by him. Oh,
he shall turn back and pay heed to those
who forsake the holy covenant and tie.
Cause the fourth will pay attention to
the Jews who have forsaken the Torah
forces sent by him shall occupy and
profane the temple and the fortress.
They shall abolish the regular burnt
offering and set up the abomination that
makes desolate or in some modern English
translations like the the, the uh,
abomination of desolation.
That term will be used also in the
new testament in several places.
He shall seduced with intrigue
those who violate the Covenant.
That is the bad Jews
who violated the Torah.
He will be in cahoots with and Ticus but
the people who are loyal to their God
shall stand firm and take action.
The wise among the people shall
give understanding to many.
And for some days however they shall
fall by sword and flame and suffer
captivity and plunder who are the wise,
the author of the Book Memories.
He spent the whole first part about
setting up Daniel as a wise man.
So this author writing
into the name of Daniel,
a wise man identifies other wise Jews
of his own day and he says they're gonna
oppose and Ticus the fourth and
some of them will die because of it.
When they fall victim,
they shall receive a little
help and many shall join them.
Insincerely some scholars
believe that this is this,
that this little help may be this
author's reference to Judas Maccabeus
and maybe that he knows that there is an
armed resistance and it's a little bit
of help,
but he doesn't believe himself that the
answer to Antiochus the fourth is going
to be an armed revolt. He believes that
it's not going to ultimately succeed. Why?
Because God's going to be
the one who'll intervene,
not Judas Maccabeus the king shall act
as he pleases. He shall exalt himself,
consider himself greater than any god.
Remember,
Antiochus Epiphanes God manifest and
shall speak horrendous things against the
god of Gods. He shall not prosper
until the period of wrath is completed.
For what is determined shall be done.
He shall pay no respect to the gods of
his ancestors or the one below by women.
He shall pay no respect to any other God.
He just consider himself greater than
all, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So it's all about setting himself up.
Now look,
he shall come into the beautiful land,
obviously talking about Judea and
tens of thousands shall fall victim,
but eat and Moab and the main part of the
ammonites, shell escape from his power.
He shall stretch forth his
hand against the countries.
And the land of Egypt shall not escape.
In other words, and talk is the force.
This time is actually
going to capture Egypt.
He's predicting he shall become ruler
of the treasures of gold and silver and
all the riches of Egypt and the Libyans
and the Ethiopians shall follow in his
train.
Not only will he overrun Egypt,
he's going to oh go west of
Egypt and Libya and south
of Egypt and take Ethiopia,
but reports from the east and the north
shout alarm him and he shall go out with
great fury to bring ruin and
complete destruction. Too many.
He shall pitch his palatial tense
between the sea. What's The c?
What's the c Mediterranean. Thank you.
Somebody is awake and the beautiful
Holy Mountain. What's the Holy Mountain?
Say it. Zion Mount Zion, which
is where Jerusalem is founded.
Yet he shall come to his
end with no one to help him.
He's not gonna do it.
Then wait a minute.
He conquers Egypt, takes
Livia, takes Ethiopia,
comes back through Judea,
sets up camp somewhere in that
coastal area between Jerusalem and the
Mediterranean and there he dies.
That didn't happen.
And talk is the fourth.
Never took all of Egypt.
He never took Ethiopia. He never
took Libya and he did eventually die,
but he died way over in Babylon.
He didn't die here.
How do we know that this document
was written around the year one 64
because this author doesn't
know the end of the story.
Notice how throughout history
he's gotten everything right.
We're not every detail,
but he's got a lot of it right?
He knows when Antiochus the
so and so wins a battle.
He knows when one of the
Ptolemies wins a battle.
He knows when they tried to have a treaty
between them and Mary off one of their
daughters to each other to,
to establish peace.
He knows when they've called truces.
He knows when the Romans intervened
and stopped, uh, battles between them.
He knows, he knows all that. He knows
that Antiochus profaned the temple.
So He's,
this has gotta be written after one 67
cause he's telling us all about this
stuff that happens with the temple.
He knows everything that happens up to
one 67 and there may be a little hint
that even knows about Judas Maccabeus,
but he doesn't know about anything that
happened to the cleansing of the temple.
He doesn't know about
the victory of Judas,
which happened in one 64 notice how
this is wonderfully convenient for us.
Modern scholars.
He gets everything right up to one 67
and every thing wrong at one 64 because
notice what happens then chapter 12 right
as Antiochus the fourth dies according
to his prophecy at that time,
Michael,
the great prince to protect your
of your people. Michael's an angel.
The greatest angel shall arise.
There'll be a time of anguish has
never been about, in other words,
this is when all hell breaks loose,
the heavens come down.
Michael swoops in the on a chariot from
the sky with angelic armies and they are
the ones who bring the final victory.
God breaks into history and
brings the final victory.
Judas Maccabeus doesn't win,
win the battle. So this,
this is how we date
apocalyptic literature.
Daniel is one of the earliest cases of
what we call apocalyptic literature.
It gives a apocalyptic CISM gives you
this vision of what's going to happen in
the very near future and it
answers the problems of suffering.
And the answer is not arm yourselves and
fight the battle yourself because the
odds are overwhelmingly against you.
You can't defeat all around,
you can't defeat all of Greece. You can't
defeat Antiochus Epiphanes by yourself,
but God can.
And so angelic armies will break into
history and bring about the solution to
the problem.
And that the apocalyptic
writer sets himself up usually
far in the distant past.
Like this guy says he's Daniel Riding
in the sixth century and they narrate
history through the agent. And you
can tell, wow, he's got it. All right.
Daniel foresaw this stuff writing
way back in the year, you know,
580 and yet he's, he knows about the
Persians, who knows, but the meats,
he knows about the Greeks,
he knows about Alexandra,
he knows about the splitting of veterans,
came go. He knows about Berenice,
he knows about the Romans.
And so you think he knows all this stuff,
he got it all right.
And you pick it up and you're reading
it in the year one 64 yourself,
one 65 and you think, well, he must be
right about what's gonna happen next.
So you think God's going to break
in any day. We're going to be saved.
We don't have to fight ourselves.
We're going to be saved.
And this is how we date apocalyptic
literature. Where do they get the history?
And then when does the history go?
When does the history just
all of a sudden go wrong?
That's when it's dated because
they're riding up to that point.
So one of the wet that won't,
that kind of apocalyptic mentality,
that apocalyptic worldview will become
very important for early Christianity
because what I'll argue in the rest
of this course is who else was an
apocalyptic prophet?
Jesus,
who else was in Apocalyptic Prophet Paul?
All of the earliest followers of Jesus
seemed to have been apocalyptic minded
Jews and that's the beginning of
early Christianity earning Christian.
He starts off as an
apocalyptic Jewish sect.
They all were reading Daniel and they are,
when they read other prophecies
from the Hebrew Bible,
they also read those apocalyptically.
So the apocalyptic response is another
one of these responses to Hellenization
in not in 63 about a hundred years
after the cleansing of the temple first.
Are there any questions
about any of that so far?
I'll give you a lot of both in confusing
history and confusing terminology.
A hundred years after the cleansing of
the temple Maso Menos in the year of 63
BCE Pompei the general of the Roman
General Pompei enters Jerusalem,
and this is when you have the
beginning of Roman control of Judea.
Herod the great gets himself appointed
as King of the Jews by the Romans,
by the Roman Senate. Only the Senate at
this time can proclaim anybody a king.
So the Senate would sometimes have
client kings on the different, the edge,
the frontiers of their control.
They couldn't,
they didn't want to be
bothered with controlling her.
The same thing themselves with their
own armies directly or their governors,
so they would appoint local kings,
whether in Asia, minor Greece,
different parts.
Herod the Great was appointed King by
the Roman Senate and he ruled from the
year 37 to the year for BCE.
After Herod the great died,
his kingdom was split up first
among his different sons,
but Judea itself eventually was placed
under direct Roman rule under procurators
that were appointed by the Senate
or sometimes by the emperor.
And this is what pilot's
job was punches pilot,
who was the governor of Judea.
His actual title wasn't governor
that he was a procurator,
but he was the one in control
of Judea during the life.
During the time that
Jesus was killed himself,
pilot was one of these
direct Roman rulers of Judea.
Galilee was ruled by a son of Herod,
the Great Herod Antipas and different
and set a descendants of Herod would rule
in different parts of that of
Palestine for many years after that,
during the first century,
there were sporadic
uprisings among the Jews.
Some of them were apocalyptic.
That is,
they seem to have been Jews who
are expecting the end to come, but,
but sometimes they seem to have expected
that they were supposed to start it.
So for example,
you have PR Josephus tells us about
Jewish prophets who would arise and say,
follow me to Jerusalem and thought of
me to Jerusalem and then stand on the
Mount of Olives,
which is this mountain is right
opposite the main mountain of Jerusalem.
And they'd say,
okay,
tomorrow we're going to go out and
we're gonna March around the walls of
Jerusalem and the walls
are all going to fall down.
Sound like anything you familiar with
the walls of Jericho and the Hebrew Bible
falling down after the Israelites
marched around it for seven days and then
seven times the last day prophets were
arising using inspiration from Jewish
prophets from the ancient past.
And they were setting themselves up again,
his profits and again
expecting God to break through.
So sometimes these profits arose and
they were themselves apocalyptic profits
announcing the end of the known
world soon. Sometimes also,
they seem to have been setting themselves
up as king of the Jews and that would
make them a messiah because the word
Messiah and he booed just means the
anointed one. And what do you
do when you make someone a king?
In the ancient world, you put oil
on their heads. That's how you,
you anoint a king. So if someone's called
the anointed one, that's a kingly title.
Now this is very dangerous because what
did I just say about how did you get to
be a king and run when controlled area?
The senate had to punch you.
Anybody who set himself up as king without
being appointed king by the Senate,
that was itself an act of treason.
So there were the other messianic figures
who would rise and try to provoke some
kind of revolt.
The most important revolt of the Jewish
people during this time started the year
66. Now we're in the common
era. So this is 66 CE.
It started in 66 with Jews in both Judea
and Galilee revolting against Roman
rule. They drove the Roman,
uh, squadron out of Jerusalem,
and in the year 70, the Romans, finally,
after four years, four years of warfare,
they had surrounded Jerusalem
for a full two years.
They finally took Jerusalem itself.
They flattened,
they destroyed the temple. So the
destruction of the temple is the year 70.
And that's probably the most important
date for this course because a lot of
important things in Christianity,
the early Jesus Movement, uh,
happen either before 70 and
there one kind of event.
Some of them happen
right around the year 70.
We'll talk about that when we get to the
gospel of Mark and a couple of times.
And then some of them, uh, most
things happen after you're 70.
But the destruction of the
temple in Jerusalem in the
year 70 is not only hugely
important for Jews, right?
Because ever since then,
Jews have not had a sacrificial
cult where if you're a Jew now,
where do you go to sacrifice?
You can't go to the temple.
There's the Dome of the rock sitting
there on a where it's supposed to be.
Jews substituted different forms of piety,
reading the Torah,
studying, praying, meeting in
synagogues, meeting and other places. Uh,
so Judaism changed radically
beginning in the year 70,
precisely because the place where
you sacrificed was destroyed.
Every er, every ethnic group around the
Mediterranean, in the ancient world head,
it's religion as some part of sacrifice.
They all did.
Sacrifice was just common among different
groups around the Mediterranean.
The year 70 calls the Jews to stop being
primarily a sacrificial people cause
they hadn't heard the sacrifice.
The end of the Jewish war is
dated by most people to 74,
because that's the time when
the final battle took place.
And the fortress that fell was called
Masada.
So if you go to Israel now,
Masada is a shrine for
tourist spot in a shrine
that celebrates the, uh, defeat
of the last or Jews, Jews,
uh,
at Masada.
The fortress that Herod the
great had built after that
Judaism changes. You have,
um, I'm not going to go into much
detail because the way rabbinic Judaism,
what you know is Judaism today,
if you know anything about it at all,
is a result of developments
that happen after 70.
It's the result of the rabbis recognizing
that the temple cult is no longer
there. The rabbis who are teachers of
the law and commentators on the law,
they become the central organizing
feature, not the priests.
So priest, the priesthood, you
still have Jews named Cohen, right?
Which means priest, but priest and
Judaism don't really do much anymore.
It's the rabbi's you become important.
So at the beginning of,
around the year 200,
you have the rabbinic Judaism starting to
develop its written texts, the Mishnah,
the Babylonian Talmud,
the Jerusalem Talmud.
And this is the birth during these
centuries of ribbon ism that is rabbinic
Judaism as it comes to be important.
There was another Jewish revolt in one 32,
two one 35 called the Bar Kokhba revolt.
But that was suppressed by the
emperor Hadrian and one 35.
And that you had the complete
destruction of Jerusalem. It was leveled.
It was renamed Eylea capitol,
Alina or Roman name and Jews after that
were forbidden even to enter Jerusalem
for a long time. Okay. What's
important about all this? I told you,
I warned you last time, that last
lecture on the Grock, the Roman empire,
the Greek world was going to be some just
boring historical narrative and you've
had some of the same thing this time
where I just had to tell the story of what
was going on in these centuries,
but why was this unimportant for us?
Here are the main things
to take away from it.
Hellenization was extremely
important because it United,
the Mediterranean world,
the eastern Mediterranean,
but then the Romans even took over some
of the aspects of Hellenization when
they took over all of Mediterranean.
By Jesus time,
all of Palestine was
hellenized to some extent,
only to different degrees.
So yes,
if you are living in a village
or in the country, you didn't,
you may not have spoken Greek
may I spoke in Hebrew or Aramaic,
but if you were an elite person in
any city, even in Palestine at time,
you are expected to be
able to speak Greek.
You had some exposure to Greek culture.
Syncretism was very important.
The idea that religions around
religions borrowed from each other.
Religions were mixtures of things and
cultures borrowed from each other.
So syncretism was very important.
There was also conflict within Judaism.
I tried to emphasize that Jews weren't
all agreed about how to respond to the
things, to the politics and
the cultures around them.
Jews conflict with Jews over how to adopt,
adapt to a Greek and Roman
domination and culture, political,
social, religious,
linguistic, cultural issues.
We're all effected in some way.
The next really important thing is the
smallest of Judea from the modern world.
We tend to think of Jerusalem and Judy
as being very important because of course
that's where Judaism started off and
that's where Christianity started off.
But by the standards of
the Greek and Roman worlds,
Judea was a kind of insignificant
backwater. It wasn't a big empire,
important place economically
or politically and Jerusalem
was not that terribly
important. Judea was relatively
unimportant from a world
historical perspective,
but,
and this is also very important for how
this lecture plays out for the rest of
the course.
The Jews were never truly
independent during this time,
nor were they ever truly powerful
during this time, even when the Hazmat,
Ian's Judas Maccabeus in his brothers
and their descendants were ruling for 100
years or so,
they never were politically very powerful
outside of that narrow area of Judea.
They were never truly independent.
They always had to fend off the greater
power of Syria or Egypt or Rome.
That difference.
The important thing though is Jews had
an ideology that supported imperial
pretensions.
Go back and read the first few songs
where God says to my anointed one,
and here he's either talking to King
David or whoever is supposed to be sitting
on King David's throne.
You are the king of the world.
I will make all the
nations flow to Jerusalem.
All of them will come and
worship me in this holy place.
The songs are full of language that
imply that whoever is in control and
Jerusalem is the king of the world,
and yet the Jews looked around themselves.
And again,
we haven't had anybody who
approached that in centuries.
The Jews had an ideology of empire
and world domination embedded in their
scripture,
and yet their social and political
situation was just the opposite.
And it's in that Maelstrom of
Jewish ideology not fitting
reality that Jesus was
born
no sections this week. Look
at the syllabus. On Monday,
you'll be asked to come in with lists
of historical events as you see them in
acts and list of historical events as
you've seen them in Galatians one to come
in with your lists on paper, because
we're going to put it up on the board.
Be prepared to tell me what you do for
your homework and do the homework for
Monday. Okay? It's not very difficult.
I won't take you a long time,
but follow the syllabus instructions
and come Monday ready to talk.
Thank you.